[Musique]
c'est une journée presque comme les
autres à central park
mais si le soleil était au rendez vous
l'ombre du corps en un virus n'est
jamais très loin et pèse comme une épée
de damoclès au dessus des têtes
ma tante elle travaille dans l'armée
elle l'a eu en rapportant des vivres et
des aides ou peut-être en étant en
contact avec divers types de jantes ou
en voyageant donc à la fin elle a fini
par l'avoir mais elle en a guéri elle va
mieux elle était vraiment dans un état
critique a craché du sang à avoir une
grosse fièvre et tout ça mais là
seulement 29 ans alors son système
immunitaire a pu faire face à deux pas
de l'hôtel de ville de new york
marie meldrum elle mène un autre combat
au chômage et sans ressources ont raison
du confinement
elle s'est jointe à cette poignée de
manifestants qui réclament à l'état de
new york
le droit de reprendre le travail quoi
qu'il en coûte
[Musique]
absolument je ne sais plus quoi faire
on travaille est essentielle il est
essentiel car je nourris ma famille si
le gouverneur cuomo se souciait vraiment
de l'état de new york
il ne voudrait pas que les contribuables
citoyens et en bonne santé restent chez
eux et soit dans l'incapacité de
rembourser leur prêt hypothécaire ne
soit pas capable de nourrir leurs
enfants ça devient une situation
désespérée pour beaucoup de gens une
manifestation interdite rapidement
dispersés par les forces de l'ordre qui
n'hésite pas à procéder à des
arrestations
j'exerce mon droit de le réunir du
premier amendement de la constitution
américaine
ce que font ces policiers en ce moment
est illégal si ces manifestants
réclament un peu de répit le virus lui
ne fait pas de pause avec 27 mille décès
recensés depuis le début de l'épidémie
new york est l'état le plus touché par
la pandémie aux états unis
alors tous les soirs à 19h d'autres
manifestants entament eux des chants
pour rendre hommage au personnel
hospitalier
en attendant le retour à la liberté
[Musique]